so this episode is called --mode and war
hey hey
I'm started on me alright so this
episode is gonna be mo noir and the
first end is here x2 there by the way
but but this is this is BMO noir and the
first thing that pops in my head when I
saw this like from beginning to end is
that they were probably looking to save
on animation for this episode like and I
know how this works cuz I heard they
used to do this I'm going to is that
that's not a lot of animated shows do
this I just show us a general where they
put a lot of effort into a specific
episode they want to be really big maybe
only two episodes for it and then they
need not necessarily filler but just
something easier to do but with that
said I really like this episode because
I like BMO and I like film noir and I
thought this was fun and this is one of
the this set up is BMO no Finn has lost
his sock he's yelling at Jake to find it
while he's playing on eyeliner and
lipstick around his face which we kind
of got later cuz we see an arrow in his
head yeah and like that supposed to be I
kept all sigh but I never got the
eyeliner that that I missed that bounce
I bet excuse me
mascara you're gonna be in this yeah
what else is new
I'm an Internet critic that's all we do
and I blame other people for them don't
you know the drill
janitor I like being that but if I could
just blame everyone else for my mistakes
it's great yeah so so yeah so yeah and
you got her and looking around for this
sob pretty much and she's making up this
story it's like watching a little kid
make up their own adventure pretty much
um and you know it makes the little rat
talk makes the chicken talk yeah puts
the actually does little voices with it
and
I think unlike something like lumpy
Space Princess which we both really like
but week knowledge doesn't do very good
with a full episode BMO can hold an
episode BMO is really likable really
cute in my opinion uh I was really like
how you're talking to someone off camera
thank you
talking to the invisible person it's
it's very filling a wire that's what
they do all the time see it's an honor
of actually knowing that really that's
not very thing they do know you totally
close up you can't do the whole episode
like this why not
and then Jason bitched and moaned like a
whiny little bitching Mona but yes
that's the way it goes that's all I got
no but now but now that you can think we
can be German expressionistic just go on
I don't know you see the episode it's
good it's funny it's got a lot of good
angles and shadows that's black and
white and she does have to talk that
much again saving on the animation the
mouth never moves half the characters
don't even move their mouths cuz again
it's in a mind but now he's totally
William Shatner maybe a little bit yeah
I do that I'm feeling him be steps could
be a short episode you guys I'm not
myself on the floor Leo just scream that
was impressive that was actually yeah he
wasn't figure that you like really like
face-first okay okay my wife puts me
through worse she's so mean he chocolate
gummy bears but no it was so good
because I enjoyed Bebo alive and I like
don't know where the only thing I would
like to see a little bit more of maybe a
few more fun angles cuz that is what I
love the most about them to ours you can
get all these great you know the Dutch
angles the low angles and high above
what is it called Dutch angles
invented by the Dutch or could it be
like you know a slur against them maybe
like polish steadicam yeah what's polish
steadicam that's where you just like oh
oh you're even more terrible about it
goes like this
and I'm like oh yes it was but a clone
is when you a steadycam is how you're
supposed to hold the camera steady yeah
by hand polish it is just without the
thank you being a steady so it's just a
person holding it but trying to keep it
really stable polish I I think come up
with the turn I just always heard that
too I'm just like that's a fake so so
many not okay so for so long so many
like Serio types and insults it's a hand
to be taught to me because there's
because I wasn't getting the joke
sounded like I was just right now ain't
that about polish Steadicam exactly what
I love that's cuz I didn't get either I
first heard it and they serve all these
jokes about like you know whatever I
prisons religion or gender ethnicity
whatever and I was always like I don't
get it and they're always like oh dummy
I'm like I'm a dummy because I don't
hate people yes you are I guess so need
to hate more need to hate more that's
the lesson that we got from BMO noir but
yeah so it's a I like that I enjoyed it
what about the cat butthole yes
and once I can't but holding this I was
just an X of a cat's butt and it I was
just kidding I was kind of fascinated
they drew that on there I was like you
know the things that fascinated Doug you
okay I know being an artist when you
draw something it's like yet to make
that effort cause it's not like you draw
once and then that's a you have to draw
every single frame so there's a
conscious effort to say hey give that
cat an asshole and I don't know why that
conscious effort was made but what can
have assholes now according to be manu
are why don't be so difficult this
emphasize another you are being a little
bitch possibly I just throw myself on
the ground yeah
ignored it no I I nearly ended the
episode nearly like they didn't I did
because I want to hear your opinion I
think you did it I did don't even live
let's say in anyway I liked it one scene
that I'm surprised didn't bring up is
where BMO falls and has that like dream
sequence
yeah just very like over-the-top creepy
bizarre with the putting the lipstick on
then taking the lipstick off his face
turning into like a human face that was
awesome
the first thing I mean they again they
do the film Noirs a lot to like you
should I care doing to be knocked out I
have a dream and is that the clues are
kind of in the dream they're always
weird dreams it's usually my favorite
part yeah they do that but the first
thing about to my head when I saw it was
memento um they did that right down to
it's a different person's face for a lot
although they don't do it from just a
second but you know sorry hinting I
think they're hinting that like she was
doing it the whole time like way the
lipstick out which of course he was
shaking up the sounds and stuff but I
like that's like you know or is she or
not and I I thought that's my cousin
momento was never fully one okay she
never discovers that she was doing it
the whole time
Nobita lives in the dream no BMO knows
the whole time she's doing it know the
whole face thing has nothing to do with
that the whole face thing is we're
nectar nectar size oh we're both robots
and be almost like no I'm not like you
basically BMO feels that BMO is human
and that's what it was
every time the face turned all sin had
turned to a human face Beema Beema
doesn't feel that BMO is a robot BMO
feels human think about what BMO five
short graybles in front of the mirror
he's talking sheet ah it's BMO is
talking to BMO self saying help I'm a
little boy look at what I can do
BMO always wants to be human that's kind
of the point of every time BMO does
stuff I took it I could be wrong
don't yell at me yell at him I'm a
critics I blame you now ya know I always
took it as that as that yeah of course
they show him putting the lipstick on
taking it off and all that stuff but
it was one of those things where I
always took it as Bhima felt he wasn't a
robot he's human he feels that you know
be most human that's why the face turned
human well I forgot about that scene
when the grave was one where I I'm a
little boy look what I can do like it's
is that something else' pops up in later
episodes to sort of this kind of okay I
just had some I never quite picked up by
but now it's kind of interesting the
amount of love that there is be most
consistently talking about love very
protective over Finn he is a it is a
robot with a ton of emotion neptr has
kind of emotions but they're very
robotic seeming BMO is very human think
about how pissed off BMO gets when
finished in trouble or when Finn and
Jake were fighting people actually got
really upset and sad over that very not
robotic traits very human traits yeah so
you could leave neptr as they did like
whatever hided seek for life whatever
that was years or whatever ideas just
like yeah you found me and there was no
emotion at all he's just happy you know
where BMO would probably at some way to
say noumena do you know you know this is
boring I want to do something else Plus
how many other robots have that much
imagination yeah I don't know I haven't
talked to them many robots or ass how
their imaginations are but but like
neptr I don't imagine has some massive
imagination or anything like I know
probably no that's again that's I could
be wrong again with the whole him being
human and that's what the face meant but
that's what I always took it as because
BMO's very human they treat finn and
jake treat BMO very different then neptr
hmm when after they just want to get
away oh yeah mm oh is it housemate yeah
would think about when they showed up in
BMO's telling this story seems like yeah
Moe yeah I was actually wondering how
they were gonna react I really liked the
bit just to Toronto yeah okay I want to
give up that little dance she does
because that is like a horrible this
friggin adore
this whole episode just saw is adorable
because I really like them and I like
that voice it's nice to hear that voice
have a full episode yeah you know aside
from either a Rainicorn or just BMO just
these little parts because it's a very
nice soothing voice that's a very cute
voice and it's nice to hear it consume
the whole episode even when she's doing
like other characters in it you know but
yeah yeah talk and so on and so forth so
I did I like oh well that's an
interesting theory about the whole human
thing you know I'm sort of like I'm
gonna keep an eye out for that very
interesting but yeah so uh good stuff
final thoughts no keep on the girl no I
have to work up to that Wow okay let me
move this way again so am I getting shot
what is my motivation